[Musik]
robert menschen kriminell und das wollen
sie wieder auf den richtigen weg bringen
der front
[Musik]
ich bin da in der justizvollzugsanstalt
thorberg im emmental im käfig
geschichte dahinter sieht 180 x niveau
eines gemeinsam sie sind einfach alle
straffällig wurde
[Musik]
das ist der hans rudolf schwarz direktor
vom trubel danke das noch heute sie
können sie mir sagen war für menschen
sabine berg sind
das ja alles straftaten fluchtgefahr
vorausgesagt wird dass er die schwere
jungs er hätte schwere jungs ja wo wart
ihr direkt hätten ja vom bankräuber bis
zum vergewaltigen oder fünfter werden
sie alle da
sein
40 nationen insgesamt verschiedenen
situationen
wohl entsprechend 20 verschiedene
sprachen ja
es macht eindruck dass al ahli work das
sehr spezielle atmosphäre
jetzt mein luther in höhe mit es klein
ist die christen im knast wie mir so
leid war nicht einmal ihre aufgabe zu
mit einer lüge machen also ist straßburg
klagen belegen können entwickeln kann
flüchten aber
bestrafung zogen also nur bis 22 der
musste sicher machen für noch ein foto
was ich am schluss ziel vom strafvollzug
strophe oder ist es quasi wie die
gesellschaft es ist format wird die
platte gesellschaft also der richterin
der strafe gesprochen
mit jeder führer aber immer mit
perspektive da muss mit der freien
bürger und das westliche bürger wenn ich
deine menschen zu schaden wo wir
begegnen wo du ihnen sind
die täter sind
dass simoncelli der umweg wenn man
sich heute aber die größten situation
ganz anders an als tnt welthandel
senkt sagt gerade die jüngste
motorischen zeigen also noch sehr jung
aber straff mögen die geschmähte schon
sehr viel früher abziehen strafmündige
stein jugendstrafgesetz unterstellt und
die frankfurter sind für die umsätze vor
dem jugendstrafrecht sind die sogenannte
jugendarbeit
[Musik]
ein 14 jähriger drogenkonsument wartet
auf das war hier
hast du auch mit mir
gefühle
wenn jugendliche eine schöne vorstellung
machen sich größtes konzept wie sie sich
da verhalten und ich habe auch so
traurig macht wenn sie denn überrascht
sind meine noten ich sehe den dreh raus
so dasitzt dass das konzept aufgegangen
ist und nein ich mag dich sehr achtbar
und ich habe ihn überrascht und du
darfst einfach achten noch haben wir die
meiste zeit ohne job das ist im herzen
bis sie zwei jahre war johanna
konsumieren und wie oft konsumiert
stände zwei
wochen an der pulsion
wir haben größte strafe des spiels
überhaupt euro
vielleicht ist es sein aussehen
vielleicht seine verständnisvolle art
hansueli gürber gewinnt schnell das
vertrauen von jugendlichen tätern über
zweieinhalbtausend saßen ihm schon
gegenüber
wahrscheinlich zwei jahren
als jugendanwalt befragte schon seit
bald 30 jahren minderjährige sünder er
befällt auch urteile und ordnet
maßnahmen an bewusst spricht er von
seinen jugendlichen weil er sie gern hat
und ihnen perspektiven geben möchte
ivana wichtig aber der job hat dass man
das eiweiß das einzige vom ksk ja ich
bin schon mal in eine günstige situation
in russland
mit traumpaar mannschaft nicht
frustriert über die stadt aber frei
gefragt
wer sich im büro umsieht entdeckt
hinweise auf seine person
zeichen eines abenteurers und
individualisten
an schule körper ist ein mensch der sich
gegen gesellschaftliche normen stellt im
beruf und privat
[Musik]
hansueli gürber studierte jura arbeitete
danach als gericht sekretär staatsanwalt
bezirksrichter und leitender
jugendanwalt
lange zeit engagierte sich auch in der
regionalpolitik als sp mitglied der
62-jährige schont sich kaum trotz
herzproblemen und bypass operation
sehr bewusst
und dann weiß
oder auch heute sind allein geriet ich
hoffe jetzt viele hörer sprach jetzt nun
auspacken fertig
und schafft ja
das ist jetzt wieder mal auf und hätte
eigentlich so gut gefühlt das war bitter
[Musik]
die heutige fahrt führt in 62 jährigen
zu einem jugendlichen dessen
strafregister ganze ordner füllt
um diesen 17 jährigen geht es nennen wir
ihn gar los mit neuen verübte er seine
erste straftat eine sachbeschädigung es
folgten viele weitere delikte wie raub
gewalt drohung waffenbesitz drogenkonsum
um nur einige zu nennen
[Musik]
vor zwei jahren verletzte er mit dem
messer einen jugendlichen schwer dieser
überlebte nur dank großem glück
für ihre vielen drogen tief und
so bitter und so passiert das nicht
provoziert hat
naja und dann habe ich zwar nicht welche
maße für glückliche mit anschieben und
dann gehe ich weg aber die person hat
kraus büro
ja und dann hat eine schlusseinkehr kaum
dass
meisterhand kann das gemacht und lacht
ja das seien vom großen feldern was
gemacht dann ja
bei mpg den zehnfachen weltmeister im
thai boxen darf carlos mit dem segen des
jugend anwaltes trainieren
dass der 17-jährige durch erlernte
kampftechnik noch unberechenbarer wird
verneint an so liege aber bei jedem
kontrollbesuch stelle er fest dass glos
sich zum positiven entwickeln
der mensch sei veränderbar ganz
besonders der junge ihn einfach
wegzusperren findet über realitätsfern
jugendstrafe fertig der gedanke vor der
integration und der zieht und das
erreicht man nicht nur mit repression es
braucht auch repression aber nachher
muss er wirklich anders heute bis
konstruktiv blut fürs leben vorbereitet
der fall löste skandal sondergleichen
geführt wird ausgang jetzt mit dem
handrührgerät die reform auch wissen was
man eigentlich machen zum jugendlichen
straftäter wieder auf die richtige weg
zurückführe
hansueli gürber nach dem wahlchaos
einziger frühpensionierung mit
bremsen eigentlich
dazu sagen aber
der vg gold der ihnen bisher noch ohne
meine deckung und natürlich so immer
wieder hinsehen
ist ja doch tritt lagen ist das um
nichts umwerfen
und das ist auch herab auch wohl bin ich
klar eine veränderung
70 anrufe locken
hat er noch drüber über die spezielle
fall jetzt eigenen ziele aussuchen da
war
ich da zu extrem mögliches sie mit
waffen verhängt sie eigentlich suchen so
im alltag
ganz große teile vor der pause in dem
band auch wenn mir die gesamte strategie
genau machen das ist die bewegen die art
sind
einmalige lautet diebstahl wo man
eigentlich dann habe ich als sehr
schlank meister der jugend d jugend ist
nur möglich sagen okay ich hab also ja
einfach nicht die ganz ort oder sie hat
nicht eigens tausendjährige mir trug sie
das gemeistert und heute bist so
bestraft es sind ganz einfache woche die
neue jetzt alle nur jugend
kriminalstatistik von zürich und die
jugendkriminalität die golfer zum
sechsten jahr in folge und irgendwie
gelegt stiegen um über zwei prozent als
problem für ssds us gesellschaft das ist
eigentlich das handelsvolumen
die halterner der
herrscher von 20 jahren hat das zurück
nach longbond einig dass das kleine
eingriffe
was macht mit der decke jetzt gott geht
so haben vor der qual das ist es wo man
öfters mit einem 8 chance groß ist also
mit 15 20 finanz gegen aurich machen ja
ja gut sein denn nicht nur typische
aktion ist aber halt auch das problem
mit der jugendhilfe diskutiert und
fachpersonen sogar umspielt wird denn da
so jürgen sich mit dem thema muss
ausland setzt das unternehmen allerdings
war wie eine sucht im meer bestattet
die jugendlichen sagen wir im moment
sehe ich keine perspektive
gibt und ich hatte zentrale grund wo die
jugend allen franz dass es sehr viele
jugendliche hätten einfach das
finanzieren sie sind die großen frauen
von ihm perspektiven
gewandert sind motors boss die das
nämlich mehr zusammen oder davon
investieren und eine städtereise und
über das ich kann sehr unterschiedliche
war schon vor jugendlichen zurück und
glichen aber das ist so aussieht wie er
zu dem überfall gar los wo er eigentlich
brian heißt dass man schluss zuzumessen
grund flügels wort und ich hab das ist
schon so dass ich erinnert ausnahme und
das setting das ist in vielen vom
reporter hanspeter bäni 2003 hat das
öffentlichkeit gesehen überhaupt läuft
oder locken jetzt noch mal drei
29.000 franken pro monat das ist viel
geld aber der aufwand ist groß rund zehn
personen kümmern sich laufend um gar los
er habe eine persönliche betreuerin
die gebürtige iranerin ist eine art
ersatzmutter und rund um die uhr für
carlos sei für ihn der nie ein
geregeltes familienleben hatte ist es
wichtig eine bezugsperson zu haben die
beiden kannten sich vorher nicht
jugendanwaltschaft bezahlt die
viereinhalb zimmer wohnung seit einigen
monaten das gemeinsame zuhause der
beiden
ich bin froh und ja es ist nicht einfach
aber er macht er gut
hansueli gürber hat alle beteiligten die
mit garros zu tun haben zu einem
standort gespräche aufgeboten man staunt
über die stattliche gruppe die sich
hierfür sei mut sein verteidiger ist
dazu drei personen aus dem sozialbereich
weiter carlos sporttrainer und der
privatlehrer nicht dabei ist gar noch
mutter eine brasilianerin dafür ist sein
vater gekommen
big business und die können das so als
nicht so
wichtig wie das
was macht denn die toilette
montags proxy 4 mio schlicht nicht
möglich
nachdem
gibt es mit ihr
diskutieren
richtig ohne erfolg
so treten muss weniger der eine
möglichkeit ist dass zum beispiel
fitnesstrainer diffus gewesen
jetzt überlege mir noch nicht genannt
diskutiert
die jeweilige steigende primitiven
mitteln erlernt nach den acht stunden
schafft und amerika liter weg zu und du
brauchst das dauert weiß es gar nicht
kommen das ist ganz oft auch um ihren
halb acht umgeben aber du bist im
seniorenbüro trainieren in der nun auch
nur lesen und wenn der motor durch
detaillierte macht er nach deswegen weiß
ich würde mir einfach morgens gibt viele
fragen die schätze mal klinik verlegt
sich ausländer und trainiert dann geht
es richtung alle möglichkeiten das du
wenigstens verschneiten schnuppe
bisschen dreckig und kosten sagt das
kommt mir vorstelle und da costa das
passt überhaupt nicht
einfach da nennt sie einfach ganz
richtig groß raus hat sondern dass immer
probiert kramers sender sat 1
80 oder das duo zum einen bezüglich
rundschau und modisch möchte sich weiter
aus und auch das auch
garros boxprofi werden alles andere
interessiert die nicht einzig die
mitarbeiter im fitnesszentrum ist für
ihn pflicht sonst dürfe er nicht mehr
weiter trainieren sagt körber mehr druck
macht der jugendanwalt nicht auch wenn
er sich damit dem vorwurf aussetzen
kuschel justiz zu betreiben
der fall carlos erhitzt seit tagen die
gemüter bis hin zum siedepunkt
das sogenannte sommer setting führt zu
einem sturm der entrüstung
carlos hat beinahe jemanden umgebracht
und wird dafür noch belohnt für 29.000
franken pro monat
körpers vorgesetzte der oper
jugendanwalt marcel riesen und
regierungsrat martin graf gehen auf
distanz
ich jedenfalls hätte einen solchen
vertrag nie und das reden ebenfalls
nicht mit diesen kostenpositionen ich
arbeite hier kritiklosigkeit und
fehlendes fingerspitzengefühl
körper wird ruhiger irrläufer
hingestellt sein sonder setting wird
unter dem medialen druck abgebrochen
carlos wird wieder kriminell und
beschäftigt justiz bis heute inzwischen
als erwachsener
somit wählen auge mit was für gefühle
gibt sie ein ritt auf der film zu
ja denn deine ich zwar ist auch sein
denn ich das ist so flexibel in der
woche mit ihm
ist sie sagt ich bin schuld
also bist du oder minister auf
eines das nur noch vier personen waren
es noch zeit bleibt in den meisten los
ist
das ist ganz klar
dass ich mich dass ich ein großer boxer
und zweiter stelle das verruchte ich sie
dass die vorgesetzte die vorgesetzten
ich sage offen warum regierungslager
aufgehört hat da keine der haube und na
ja es gebe wenig was bewusst
das ist teil von
krautheim ohne dabei intensiv der
gesetzlich geregelt hat
das ist wie so was ich eigentlich will
sachsen und zweite wo sie einfach findet
am schluss sind mir hätte dafür hätte
der formschöne doodle trage und dass ich
mit dem trainer gestanden hieß es 2000
findet
dagegen
er hat schlecht uns einfach zeit und das
stimmt nicht
was nicht wie berichtet sind meist
bekommt die von
der who vor dem jugendraum geschossen
körpers damalige chef der jugend
antworten aussehen lässt ausrichten das
ganze sei in zahlreichen gremien und
aufsichtskommissionen bis ins detail
behandelt worden dem gebe es nichts
beizufügen
29 06 franken im monat
für die maßnahme und vielen exotischen
av danach vor eine quasi als belohnung
mit kick box training
projekt hat verstehen sie da natürlich
das tor nicht dass es ist verrückt
verrückt und es ist letztlich
gesellschaft so das muss wer antworten
sind wir bereit oder sagt man sparen
denn je
vor einem rätsel was ihr jetzt gestellt
da sind ja linie 21 trinken
weil wir früh investiert denn rechnet
sich das wie es später einige städte
jedoch ohne kriminelle karriere verpasst
der sport gesellschaft und weiblichen
so die these einer immer weiter was
sagen sie zu dem ja nicht wird sich also
glaube jugendlichen
eine reine poesie touristische und der
hat jetzt einfach wohl brief bleibt das
konnte wiederum sie ja keinen job und
nichts
dann wird später
hand noch bevor sie von dir sehen also
viel für den egotrip straffällig wurde
wenn sie im moment klappt erst lief ich
sehe also
perspektive zu schaffen für die sich
lohnen zwei jahrzehnten
gesellschaft profitiert dann
und da stellt sich generell frau oder
springt überhaupt zum menschen strophe
was nur geduldet und zum thema frau
genau was die weitere potter kollegen
des evangelisten und christof franzen in
die jva bewies gange oder entscheidung
mit inhaftiert begrenzt
wie der schweizer franken ist sie ist
nicht ein weltuntergang
meine reporter kollege christof franzen
und ich gehen für eine woche in die jva
fugees ich bin hinter der kamera die er
davor die banalität des bösen
aber die komplexität
ich berichte seit über zehn jahren über
justizthemen er ist zum nächsten mal in
einem schweizer gefängnis
wir wollen herausfinden was es bringt
menschen zu strafen
ich bin verrückt wurde zu sechs jahren
und endet bei der bahn der mäßige
einbruchdiebstahl
was wäre ohne gesang ist anarchie
geherrscht
strafe muss sein sozusagen
werk machen oder mord becker der muss
bezahlen und das system die cd und je
gefängnis
sind gerade jetzt ist sie so
auf ein zweites hotel anmutet sozusagen
am ende des tages auch du allein die
zahl am
abend dann spielt sie zum studieren
zeit um zum beispiel darüber
nachzudenken wieso er auf die schiefe
bahn geraten ist
wieso es einen platz in unserer
gesellschaft mit 30 jahren noch immer
nicht gefunden hat
wieso er anfing zu stehlen und
schließlich zum serien einbrecher wurde
mir hat es auch finanzieller ist
ausschlaggebend sie warum es so wie
traurig dass ich jetzt da bin kein geld
braucht und ich bin ein mensch ich bin
bereits für geld fast alles zu machen
viel geld löse die probleme
schlags christmas
ich als schlechte gewissen fordert darum
wirklich dass ich tat so machen dass es
greife letzte glied und reinigt die lüth
sozusagen darum habe ich die art von
kriminalität gewarnt
honig kreis kontakt haben mit dem
anderen
kilometer und 25
kurz vor seinen letzten vier
[Musik]
auftritte hat er doch ich wein zum blut
und hosten und
was nicht das coolste was unter dem er
begann sich einen namen aus schlepper zu
machen
daneben brauche quasi im akkord in
geschäftsliegenschaften ein und
finanzierte sich so seinen aufwendigen
lebensstil
[Musik]
und doch fühlen
das nicht
es singen feiern und zwar mit mit
griesheim
grund voraus auf
das gaddafi regime
besonders kinder ein bild geboren hat
das geilste
und da hatte ich so heim zu heim vom
fleck familienzuschlag familie und eine
wissmann ist an der kriminelle war
geschlagen
und nach ist vor allem an stadt heimisch
nahezu geschlossene oder klein ist oder
jugendstrafanstalten
besonders keinen dem namen
oder weniger kann man so sagen
ja
[Musik]
jetzt für eltern und musik richtet
familie vogt oder so ist im privat- wie
auch immer andere ins aussehen und du
sie die ein dass wir nicht unbedingt mit
über
50 noch die frau war 1000 mit also ist
einziger verfährt ist
das doch das ist nun mal so weit
vor dem knast stammten die frauen
schlagen
[Musik]
dass sich nicht
erwähnte sich auf der überholspur
höher schneller weiter
ein leben im scheinwerferlicht ohne
geldsorgen
alles schien möglich
das brauchen immer möglich
schwierig mit einem neuen und zeugnis
wie zu tags der migros kasse
musst du uns zu rücken ist anlege
also es wird der raum ist die
baustelle schwarzarbeit aber das ist
auch schon mit drin egal also es gab
immer
quasi in twitter
unter www twitter schritt fordert zur
strafe wieder mit der ehemalige kollegen
ja fakt ist eigentlich eine nacht findet
12.30 frank gemacht haben nach
ersichtlich wie viel du siehst du hier
halb auf dem ball der ganze monat
und ich kam gut rüber es gibt so einfach
im wege als ruhe und
die regale ganz froh sind schwer und
steinig
es gibt leute machen die entscheidende
schritt getraut sich quasi die rote
linie überschritten
andere nicht
er hat diese rote linie in der
vergangenheit immer wieder überschritten
robben strafen eine abschreckende
wirkung und lässt sich diese wirkung mit
härteren strafen steigern
diese fragen gehören zu den am besten
erforschten themen der kriminologie und
die antworten sind klar erfahren wir
unter rechtswissenschaftlichen fakultät
der universität fribourg
es wäre schön es wird funktionieren das
würde mir wünschen dass werden sondern
als s&p straft die weniger strafen der
fans verhalten stört es ein problem ist
dass das halt einfach menschliche seite
extrem komplex ist warum ist das so
warum funktioniert das nicht das
funktioniert nicht darum weil er
eigentlich mit meinem manager sind da
einfach nicht die berliner zum gast
passiert sowas passiert sondern eben
auch heute einfach mal das haben wir
möglich sehr gut ein baby schnell wie
sein manager keines rechnet das heißt
die meisten manager wüssten nicht was
passiert sie müssen irgendwie das nicht
so erlaubt das gesetz nur maler wie
selber im bereich von kein strafrecht
müsse man darf nicht der verletzung
springt sowie das damals nicht aber was
genau passiert
wenn jetzt also die straff zum beispiel
beim diebstahl von fünf jahren auf die
übersetzung dafür fünf jahre auch die
rufe setzt hat überhaupt keine was in
fünf oder sieben jahre dass ich einfach
sehr lang und wissenschaftlich
umstritten
die empirie ist also eindeutig
trotzdem sind und bleiben diese fragen
ein medialer dauerbrenner pflegen wir
hierzulande die kuscheljustiz naiv und
wirkungslos braucht es tatsächlich mehr
härte und strengere gesetze
zu teuer zu milde manchmal brauche es
statt kuscheljustiz einfach die ganz
harte tour härtere strafen sollen
dagegen jetzt heißen der nationalrat
debattiert morgen herüber sie scheint
politisch kapital mache für kein
priester
schutzstoffe umsetzen
wenn ich mir relativ sicher bin dass ich
ihn entdeckt wird und verfolgt wird das
spielt doch dass überhaupt ein tägliches
wahrscheinlichkeit und 1 bestraft sind
zentraler faktor
was genau passiert spielt gar keine
rolle also wir viel genauer auf das er
geht er wieder straff geht über spielt
überhaupt rolle zentral ist dass es
überhaupt eine strafe gibt und zwar
schnell
wenn wir nur höhere strafe gab aber in
der ökonomie jahr gabe erschreckt dass
andere ob das aber das ist nicht der
fall so seien ein mensch das war bis
jetzt hinein
wenn man hätte die strafe droht dann
werdet weniger lose straffällig sie
angestellt vor der strafe und logik
punkt 2 wenn wir direkt richtig machen
wenn man die sperren denn wie druck
ihres know me und bei den familien
ich weiß nicht ob die politiker war das
vorbild war die fortbewegung
unterstützen ob die wirklich sowie
denken jobs schrecklich dass man auch
immer sichere roland glaubt oder ob es
mehr emotionale reaktion ist wir müssen
einfach
die müssen einfach nur schwachsinn
heftig weil wir nicht in der
gesellschaft
ich bin das nicht seit 20 jährige der
mit einer blauen für den reinigungs
autos gestohlen wie mit deiner oma
gefahren und dann sie nach hersteller
und kann nicht wissen was man fange mit
deiner autos südküste bevor ich kontakt
bin ich quasi jetzt dran das auto
verscherbelt geld die schliche zählen
umlackiert und
ab die post
also jetzt war die sache jetzt weil es
vielleicht auch nicht an blickkontakt da
bin ich wieder da bin ich mit der waffe
alles ist jetzt möglich die damen sind
aber natürlich ist der werk als erstes
legal
aus amateuren können hier drin also
profi verbrecher werden das ziel des
strafvollzuges ist freilich ein anderes
diese menschen auf die freiheit
vorzubereiten und das in einem umfeld
das mit der freiheit wenig bis nichts zu
tun hat
um diesem problem zu begegnen erfolgt
der strafvollzug wenn immer möglich
progressiv von einer geschlossenen
anstalt gibt es irgendwann in eine
offene
immer mehr freiräume sollen helfen sie
schrittweise wieder in die gesellschaft
einzugliedern
george hat er diese chance auch
er bewährte sich allerdings nicht im
offenen vollzug
darum ging es zurück in die
geschlossenheit
der lehre auch das thema noch eine lehre
machen daher habe ich das viel
tierisches aktionsideen erleben
wie sony will
das sind so gesagt ein belehren oder an
lehrern da hast du mich war nicht
automechaniker lernen sondern nur reifen
kräftiger aber immerhin
über gartner
ich fand das natürlich sowieso und
wiederum stand trainer
muss ich mich auf andere sachen
konzentrieren
klaro vor allem darin dass man
klarkommen
ein paar wochen später wir sind zurück
in der jva beschließt
nochmal schon vor ort war
hier bis nach
georgia hat seine strafe bis auf den
letzten tag abgesessen
heute wird er entlassen
[Musik]
ich bin der rundgang riesig sind
ja und gefühl so nach sieben jahren
es ist wie wenn so ein riesen stein
resultiert
ja gut
auf
nimmerwiedersehen
das ist alles ein ganzes hab und gut
wurde letzte filiale bilder schmeckt
noch
keine bilder
ein kollege erwartet ihn vor dieser tür
und natürlich auch die freiheit
[Musik]
ob ihn die frage
schon einig dann erstmal
vermutlich
also hey wo ich das
zumindest österreich dann
eigentlich da noch ganz viele bunte
scheine
sehen sie das das hat mir die kraft das
make it rain
investieren jetzt wird investiert
aber erst noch ermittelt wird
eigentlich ein cooler job
ich hoffe jährigen meldet sich bei mir
und bietet mir den job ich nehme alle
sorgen
niemand
erklären verdienen
ich hoffe
ich bleibe amerikaner verbinden
vor den chören unglück bis einfach ist
franzen am schluss von der reportage
zeigt sich das htc
tattoo sich aus dem gefängnis erwartet
da in zürich freundin untersuchen nur
hat es im leben da waren selbst ganz
europa zählen
weil er noch keine eigene bleibe habt
ist giorgio bei seiner freundin
untergekommen
[Musik]
george ovi finnisch für dem geld mehr
übrig wo sie im ressort frauen zum
schluss vor dem film zeigten
wenn man so vielleicht gar nicht und
genau zu wohlstand
erstmals investiert die handy und das
hat man ungefähr 300 kostet partei daran
die mittel müssen auf alles
was
sie
besitzen aber
es macht man doch so verfahren dass auch
sobisch gemessen also anders schlagen
ich bewerbe wirklich oder ist es eine
sehr schöne idee was bis jetzt soll man
groß geworden weil ich bin ja gedacht
frisch muss also zurück noch im
halbschlaf resch
ja und ich habe auch glück keiner will
ich eine freundin von dieter zieht und
sie hat mir unterstützt und noch ein
paar andere sachen
ja aber oder ich stelle mir das so vor
wenn unser hund dann versuchen wir
möglichst schnell leben history sie im
leben also also ich habe einen job
wäre das erste rein oder
ja schon mal ein klar der minister
relativ klar sie dass ich gewusst haben
also einfach nicht aber ich finde ja und
dann ist ja
ich glaube dass jetzt mal langsam aber
die innere ob sie das internet machen es
innerhalb von sieben jahren
also ich wollte seiner mannschaft will
ich mal vor luft musik konzentrieren 30
cents haupt sie
genau das so der arbeitstitel kann das
nicht macht bis jetzt im la werkschau
von morgen bis am abend
stehen wir das schwierig vor aber alle
anderen sozial
und ich bin
sicher dass amazon in der druckerei
arbeitet zwingt gerade oder so wie man
theoretisch gut also
groß ist die chance
dass sie irgendwann wieder kriminell
werden
ja jetzt geht die sorge will
und witz alt war dafür das haben wir
ihnen vorstellen wie die brache war und
irgendwelche faßhuber latte und
ja er kann so viel zeit verschwendet die
nachts gemeldet
verschenkt sozusagen
für jugendliche leichtsinn damals
in dem namenspatron a vorstellen dass
wir jetzt davon
ab chs kleines musikalisches
talent mitgemacht und so zeuge gut sie
sind serie taxi
steigt aber anders angefangen mit
kristalle und hat sich nach
will ich nicht erwischt wurde bin in
flagranti anime tank der um normal der
nummer und dritte glaubt
man aber immer durch glaubt dass sich
niemand verletzt dass er dann gehabt
und gail geklappt und dann alles wieder
macht etwas glück hat
sie einen gewissen anspruch als
lebendiges
lebenskrise
weitere etc
und auf die alte tradition kennt oder
also der widerspruch zwischen anspruch
und wirklichkeit
der gc
es ist ja auch so dass ich das machen
muss was ich liebe das sie von pistolesi
wenn es nicht gern mache es ist wie
schnell sie wäre printing seite das
gefängnis in unsere geschichte
hat sie sich höchst mehr oder weniger
die dokumentation über mögliche ursachen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
die losnummer zu starten und so begann
die tour schließlich eine integrierte
bis sie weiß warum schlank routine
branche zu hoch
wir sind nicht der auch gehört dass
georgia seit wie ist es wenn sie
erfahren dass georgia so lange im verein
stehen sie reagiert kann aber schon früh
erkannt und dass er damit richtig warten
aus aber solang empfang ist sich dann
einfach kalte dusche und
37 jahre im gefängnis
was heißt das für sie
ja es muss sage
max oder lang wachsen
wo ein unfall so ja so wie man halt mit
anderen unrat oder mit anderen ist
welches ja er ist jetzt
dass er jetzt ziemlich
hat nur noch sieglose jorge und sich
kreis miteinander wechseln und dadurch
glaube ich wird nicht egoistisch was
völlig nachvollziehbar ich will ja nicht
wo man muss auf sich selber nur das
verändert ziemlich viele einem würde ich
jetzt mal behaupten
eins ist für wird george irgendein weder
kriminell oder hat aber hinter sich
lässt glaubt dass
viele hat jetzt kein grund dazu wo ist
gott
glaube diese stadt zürich und ich halten
natürlich alle wo also ich habe auf jede
frau gewesen
das wird nicht gemacht hat es nicht
nötig also
geschaffen so gut wie
geschaffen fürs geld 15 jahren englisch
kommen kruse also ich einen
abgeschlossen lehrer sind das ist dank
geschafft aber auch in rabat möglichst
wenig
aus aber nicht so gern schaffen und ich
habe ziemlich nachvollziehen weil er
seit ja ich möchte zurück in meine
betrieb vom andere monfils frankreich
und dann hast du ganz natur geschaffen
als beruf wie es immer wichtiger sich
als ziemlich neu produziert und ich
finde da mancher
es gibt ja so viele stars sangen
bekannte lied ist gewährt bekommt durch
dummheit
und deswegen finde ich halt einfach ein
us dollar hat der vorgeschichte ein
ziemlich alles was ist dazu benötigt
also hoffen dummheit naja so war dunkel
und ich finde er sollte jetzt ja auf der
schiene aus ja peter lucke was ich da
sah er hat jetzt einen abschluss oder so
wenn man irgendwann nicht einfach an der
sany zwei jahren machen dann unbedingt
den job nicht aber sowieso wenn sie
jetzt in zukunft die organ- oder das ist
eigentlich stil thomas musiker statt
ich habe jetzt alles auf die karte
gesetzt und
verfolgt das ziel streben
100 aus ist es so abwegig wie latin
ersten auftritt hatte bald wieder einer
vielleicht glück hat und den text wird
beweisen kann das schnell mal wieder
ärger oder er aber es hatte glück das
land hätte auf jeden fall dazu und wir
sind weg sie wieder mehr stellen
auftritt scorpio
im kanton thurgau dass ihr christen
reporter hat die weiter begleitet
samstagmorgen kurz vor halb acht in
zürich wipkingen
ganz entgegen seinen gewohnheiten ist
giorgio bereits am vormittag
aufgestanden denn er muss zum soundcheck
in die ostschweiz in
einer partie im thurgauischen stettfurt
hat er heute seinen ersten auftritt
und so geht's los sind sie nervös
ja schon so lange zusammen
[Musik]
anthony delhi nach der entlassung aus
dem gefängnis abgeholt hat ist
vorbeigekommen zeit fürs frühstück sagt
george
das heißt bei ihm zeit für den ersten st
[Musik]
bisher lebte von seinem ersparten und
auf kosten seiner freundin und kollegin
jetzt hat er sich beim sozialamt
angemeldet
ein kollege fährt ihn zum auftritt
zu
auftritt dass man die bühne abriss
die ph ist wohl
dass rocker
ein paar stunden später in der badi
stettfurt
[Musik]
den ganzen tag dreht den newcomer auf
zürich mit tuba heißt die veranstaltung
[Musik]
dann wird die bühne ab krise sie sind
aber
[Musik]
pop ist womöglich die einzige branche in
der eine kriminelle vergangenheit ein
vorteil sein kann ein echter ex-knacki
unter vielen möchtegern gangster
erstmal dass wir das glaubwürdigkeit
verschafft also im kleinsten fehler
genau so genannte deine musik ist das
eher eine höhere pluspunkt man da
gewinnen ist am tag und sage
[Musik]
derzeit wird aber immer
wenn es leicht wird wissen
[Musik]
georgia musste wegen dem soundcheck
schon am vormittag vor ort sein jetzt
heißt es warten
immerhin winken 200 franken gage
erst kurz vor mitternacht ist es soweit
[Musik]
wieso strafen wir wie tun wir es und was
bringt das
damit befasste sich die philosophie seit
jahrhunderten sagt die sportart und die
antworten seien viel komplexer als die
scheinbar banalen fragen es vermuten
ließen
im volksmund straff nur sie aber ist es
wirklich so bossard philosoph moderator
von den sternstunden für srf es geht der
satz ins mark testament der bibel auge
um auge zahn um zahn wo eigentlich
vorher gleiches mit gleichem vergelten
jetzt wo das aus als ob gerechtigkeit
grundsatz gelte ja das ist das
sogenannte teil ions prinzip und ausruf
klar ich bin immer noch erkrankt aber
später ist das grund beim 70 und
rechtfertigung verstopfen es ist wie es
ist ist ungleichgewicht kommen muss das
virus kann sich das auge um auge also
wenn ich sie ja leicht zurück wirkt da
bist du noch berechtigt mir das gleiche
leid zuerst genau und der ist weder im
lola und das ist alles okay und du bist
wieder sozusagen befreit
warum macht das besser wenn du noch 100
lied ist also geschlossen verholfen darf
ich dir aufschlagen das immer wieder
eben genau aber mehr durch vw und der
jetzt zu setzen also wenn dies das
kohlefeld nicht bessert versuche dass es
nicht normal dazu geholt also dass man
mit der irgendwie hast du vielleicht
schuldgefühle wirklich nicht wirklich
und dass man das material täter und
opfer von anzuerkennen und versucht es
verstehe warum hat etwas gemacht dass
ich vielleicht die raucher verzeichnet
das mini rachegefühle weg können und so
sind ganz andere dynamik drin als dass
das thalia als prinzip war einfach heißt
du mir ein schloss und dann ist gut
hitze tagsüber mehr wir spannen kein
schlechtes irgendwie ihk den heim-pc was
früher noch ein opportunist um zu
menschen bestrafen was sagt strafe auch
über gesellschaften das ist eine große
freude dass es geht untersuchen und
französische philosoph historiker michel
foucault überwachen und strafen als
untersucht hat über verschiedene
jahrhundert diese straf- sie stehen
verändert hat und vielleicht ganz
einfach kann man sage es gott von einer
abschreckung mediziner prävention es
sich nur so grausam es wird mehr
psychologisch gemacht dass eine
pathologie siert also sieht das ja nicht
dass weniger die vorstrafe sondern krank
nicht sehr verschlossen man muss sehr
viel ich hörte der lauf um dein
lieblings büro was da passiert also es
werden marginalisiert und es wird mehr
auf prävention gelegt also auf
abschreckung aus den bekannten gründen
gesprochen
es gibt aber klären diese tendenz die
bevölkerung deine fällt das dass man das
stroh wirklich gesät oder vor der tür
und das wort kuscheljustiz dem
sinnvollen schöne zeile und der garten
fernsehen drehen und sich therapie wo
der staat zahlt ist das kulturbüro
kriegt dafür dass eigentlich das
rachebedürfnis menschen drin steckt
wirklich sagen also psychologisch haben
wir es genauso klar also ich stelle mir
vor wie ein täter sich am ihrer tochter
verkauft sagt jährigen und so ich glaube
das sind sachen passiert wo so viel
braucht um zeige ich wünschte eine
person nicht tot und und die hätten
zweite chance für die enten zu bitter
aber das sind
grundrecht für den staat und die heime
harter kampf die sind erkämpft wurde in
der ruf klar gott zu mensch erreicht
unter mancher wird die wir letztlich
jede für die internet und das ist so
schwierig dass der konflikt
psychologisch betroffen sie das
rachebedürfnis war sehr tief ist trainer
setzt spüre aber nichts wissen das kommt
letztlich und gerechtigkeit und
menschenwürde
es gibt menschen die bereit und egal wie
immer sie bestraft und eine verteiler
das ist ein notorischer betrüger der
josef jakobs ist neuer boardconnect
hanspeter bäni hat ihn begleitet und
zwar bis zum schluss
diese geschichte endet in einem
gemeinschaftsgrab in der ostschweiz und
so fängt sie an in der strafanstalt
saxerriet im kanton st gallen er
verbüßte der damals 57 jährige josef
jakob eine freiheitsstrafe meine geld
veruntreut und urkunden gefälscht hatte
seine opfer vor allem kleinanleger
überprüft
ich hab mich rechtfertigen oder
entschuldigen aber wenn sie die weltbank
das fürs altpapier
versuchen sie mal ein kurzzeit
aus schlitz gespräch mit der leitung der
strafanstalt
gefängnisdirektor martin vinzenz will
dass jakob flüge wert
monate bis sie entlassen werden und
jetzt mir so langsam
dass sie mit
den kremlgegner und einige gedacht dass
ich einigermaßen
ich hoffe insel die
östlich
zwischen die not und der
jetzt will ich aber das ist uns schon
ein bisschen
stolz ist
[Musik]
sieben monate nach seiner entlassung
steht jakob erneut ins finanzgeschäft 1
[Musik]
das renovieren
ersetze den grund der offizielle empfang
da gibt es vier arbeitsplätze für die
immobilienverwaltung
es wird von dem er
immer größter die firma ja die fäden
das ist im grund nur
als büro
management abteilung
und genau das ist aber geschlossen
werden das ist der anteilige immobilien
erinnern hat
jakob kann überzeugend auftreten und
versteht es menschen zu manipulieren
dingen nun nennt das sich
vermögensverwalters ich denke das
startkapital stammen von leuten die im
hintergrund bleiben wollen behauptet wer
josef jakob ist also wieder in jene
branche tätig in der frühe kriminelle
wurde
die idee
peter sich wie im beruf dass ich mich
schöner und die 2
ganz klar nein eigentlich sie dass ich
zu den spitzel die dem management
und die betriebswirtschaft
ich bin nicht gleich bentrup und aber
einem maximum an betrüger aber sicher
kann trotz 0 und doppel also ich meine
ich dass betrüger
das ist definitiv vergangenheit als also
ist definitiv
ein
verbrechen
seit drei monaten ist josef jakob wieder
geschäftlich aktiv
dann kommt dieser mann ins spiel denn
wir bruno es nennen es wurde auf ein
verlockendes inserat aufmerksam dass von
jakob stammte er suche einen
geschäftspartner schrieb der
vorbestrafte betrüger mit einem darlehen
von 20000 franken könne man sofort
einsteigen es bezahlte später stellte er
fest dass die firma gar nie gegründet
wurde bruno s will nun gerichtlich
vorgehen also wenn sie jetzt die
unterlage warum verbraucher ist
das dokument zeige wo der jakobiner
ausgestellt hat und sie betrogen hat wie
sie sagen
hat eine firma
gründet schossen gründungsfest der stand
der stammtische sehr stolz darauf jedes
dokument hat der stern produkte projekte
das ist jetzt alles noch in der
seelsorge gründet und wie groß ist ein
schatten zone wo sie jetzt
sehr gründlich vor erster instanz wurde
gerade bangkok wird war jetzt etwas
anderes
kam im geschäft und schon hat er wieder
eine klage am haus doch scheint ihn aber
nicht zu kümmern im gegenteil wir werden
uns einerseits bruno s verklagen wegen
rufschädigung
jakob hat auch eine klare vorstellung
davon was mit dem darlehen geschehen
soll
das darlehen soll dem nitrogen mehreren
job angerichtet das gehört sie genau er
seite das ganz egal verloren 20
frauenklinik gehen sind sie bereinigt um
punkt dass es um veruntreute auf das
geht nicht und ich habe auch als
download rund um die
interaktive kundiger was machen und du
hast aber nicht unterm strich 20 franken
sind wurde er jetzt wieder gegenzug die
vor ihnen nein er muss mit der bezahlung
im dezember 2007 wird josef jakob
verhaftet die feiertage verbringt er in
einer zelle im untersuchungsraum gossau
bruno s hat das urteil per post erhalten
das bezirksgericht gibt ihm recht jakob
muss das darlehen von 20000 franken
zurückzahlen und obendrauf noch einen
monatslohn
die weste trägt er zur strafe das
bezirksgericht verurteilte josef jakob
zu 500 stunden gemeinnütziger arbeit
zweimal pro woche muss er nun im
thurgauischen rickenbach für ordnung
sorgen
was ist denn ihre aufgabe konkret ist
ein
quartier kontrollieren lagen im sausal
admira öffentliche den puzzle
kontrolliert
ein paar jahre später ist seine welt
komplett auf den kopf gestellt
josef jakob hat eine niederschmetternde
diagnose bekommen nieren und blasenkrebs
ein maßstab aber
sicher dass wir sie bekanntgeben
das beben war rappaz
wenn ich zeige ihnen ganz offen der
heben trotz der ganzen sache und so
beweisen miteinander und es selbst nicht
geburtstag viele tote europa geordnet
nie
es ist traurig dass das
prominente
militärisch
interessiert an der britischen amazon
sein größtes gegangen als notfall ins
spital
die ganz woche bis jetzt noch nie
telefoniert oder psychische
himmeltraurig er führte viele menschen
an der nase herum selbst nahe verwandte
nun muss er fast allein mit seinem
schicksal zu recht kommen der reporter
wird zu seiner einzigen bezugsperson
[Musik]
ein jahr ist es her seit man bei ihm
krebs diagnostiziert hat
am
mittwoch findet einzige szene
das heißt ich muss
sagen so wenige
was
[Musik]
ich sehe
was heißt die camerata
die villacher die hälfte
das älterwerden der geringe status und
einsamkeit widersprechen seinem
aufgeblähten selbst ich wohne tagtäglich
ihrer vernehmung zu ich bin für mich
fertig los also die späte meine am
besten nicht immer langsam
es sieht sich in der opferrolle
daher mit nonchalance und auch mit dem
sozialen wieder biss dann vermehrt
redet das nun mit mir gemeint ist
positiv wenn du so wenn sie
genauer
vorteile die andere mannschaft
jan aktuelle zum ausschuss zuzogen
[Musik]
betrüger aber ein verzerrtes selbstbild
sie manipulieren andere und sind
egoisten ohne jede hemmung
kürzlich ist er in eine wohnung mit
gartensitzplatz umgezogen doch sein
leben wird überschattet von erneuten
gesundheitlichen problemen
wir stehen jetzt diagnose
losgeht
[Musik]
nicht nur browser und nieren sind vom
krebs befallen auch in der prostata und
harnröhre fanden die ärzte ableger dazu
hat er noch ein herzleiden
[Musik]
davids g2
schon um das baden am abend geht mit
kraft und gesundheit dass sie das alles
hl fehler nach dem wunsch
geht mit sonntag geht mit
70 jahre alt ist er inzwischen
geschwächt von seiner krankheit möchte
jakob ein letztes interview geben
das schließe der abschluss wurde
bei uns sehr einfach
besser
machen kann
man dies nicht
die
einzige wollen wir machen aber
das ist ganz
alt
aussehen kommt zwar schwach
ganz geheilt sein
also
das ist genau
das was ich sage ja
ja
dazu wird es nicht mehr kommen
das war seine letzte begegnung mit dem
reporter
[Musik]
und so endete diese geschichte in einem
gemeinschaftsgrab in der ostschweiz
[Musik]
wir sind zurück der in triberg und zwar
in einer arrestzelle clown wird selber
mit dem direktor hans rudolf schwarz
rabbi shlomo vorrat erhält
der josef jakob da steckt ein
notorischer betrüger
ich ahne was
resozialisieren hätte ein unterstand
keine sehr wichtig wenn ihr können seit
ich vor dieser saison das ist wirklich
ein los namen aller welt us-medien der
fahrer ist
kriminell lieber für eine lappalie
option die meisten strafgefangene hier
die veranda wagdi war ihnen ewig
betrüger lügner also verstecken
menschen generell dazu erbringt
kriminell 22
also das ist so fedderwitz haken es gibt
leute die
soziale kälte
der schwierigkeit das verladen
abbruch voller erde schuh denn betrogene
kontakte dann gibt es persönlichkeiten
wo haut einfach mal eine sich hunderte
sich verankerungen für die jena
dann gibt's auto illegal aufhalten denn
risiko und zur kriminalität römer und da
gibt es die ganz große palette von der
psychischen krankheit
was für den schluss auf zu dass man
einen weg zu finden
tatsächlich habe ich fix problemen oder
dass wir keine alternative gibt wenn
passiert wechseln also danke
strafvollzug durch kriegs oder
strafvollzug werk das noch die
kriminalität oder fängt
denn ich habe aber so wichtig
förderliche beziehen darum ist ganz
wichtig das motto besteuern aids-kranke
sie gerät dass man da probiert sie holte
um den hund dazu
kriminelles umfeld was ganz schwieriges
aber ganz wichtige arbeit die
weinberge arbeitet wendla wird denn die
chance dass sie zurückkommt relativ
jetzt kostet sehr viel geld
und bringe
120 franken
darum sage ich wollt ihr
ja 120 franken günstiger bis zur halbe
million gar je nach therapieangebot und
gesundheitskosten verursachen
schlossen foto gestört also für sommer
zu rechnen
achtung die musikwerke und haft da staut
umfasst 250 mio
stärkstes ist und der betrieb mio
vontobel hat zwölf personen die
tierbetreuung also jedes mal mitzuteilen
64 arbeitsleben mit drei personen
die
sagen dann lohnt sich also viel qualität
das lohnt sich auf jeden fall
also durch schwarz kriminalität das ist
mir ein phänomen das ganze gerede für
ganz wenig straftäterin warum ist
eigentlich
sehr interessant bayerisches 7 zwischen
56 prozent
war die kriminalität auf doch und das
ist über die jahrzehnte eben möglich
bleiben der kulturkalender fordert
daher dort emanzipation mit kann der
traum dass wegen eine seele so also zum
glück momentan
zinsniveau ist plötzlich auch kriminell
werden sieht man also viel krimineller
frauen auf smart beantworten schuss ist
weniger wahrscheinlich
anderen umgang
mit konflikten oder sogar ohne den
porsche carrera
und die
haut das ist wahrscheinlich schon
erfolgt
us täter gibt da gibt es auch opfer
diese müssen ihr trauma oft allein
verarbeiten genau da setzt die
restaurative justiz an die vier täter
und opfer zusammen um den opfer bei der
verarbeitung zu helfen
dank des minimalen victoza also wirklich
dank wird sich stetig
am 15 januar 1995 wurde die
postangestellte lsb kuba überfallen
jahre lang leitet sie unter der tat kann
nicht vergessen was hier passiert ist
kurz vor schalterschluss dringen hier
drei maskierte räuber ein fesseln lsb
kobler und andere angestellte die räuber
flüchteten mit 50000 franken bargeld
der haupttäter war rudys abo der mitte
der 90er jahre das zürcher oberland mit
mehreren raubüberfällen unsicher machte
er erinnert sich wie
eine geladene waffe sind drei personen
rückseite baustahl programm zählen ist
von der tages in
angola und bei schlossen tag 7
und daheim sie bedroht gab und könnte
das geld im sack hat und wenn viele
viele jahre heimlich unser autor und
kritiker immer wieder überfalle lacht
und
ich
konnte bis jetzt noch nicht kenne
verzehr
nur die sabo kommt für neun jahre hinter
gitter als er nach dem siebten
raubüberfall gefasst wird im gefängnis
macht er eine therapie lernt zu seinen
taten zu stehen
strafanstalt lenzburg hier wird zum
ersten mal in der schweiz ein
pilotprojekt durchgeführt
die opfer können den tätern sagen wie
stark sie die tat belastet hat ziel ist
es den opfern zu helfen das erlebte
aufzuarbeiten
die täter sollen lernen sich in die
opfer hineinzufühlen louis sako redet
klartext
hier wäre es meine geschichte
mitbekommen was ich aus gefressen habe
ich werde offen und ehrlich sagen was
für ein schwein das ich war habe
menschen schwerstens verletzt
und dann erzählt 1b kobler passiert
passiert ist
15 januar sind ihre befallen worden sie
haben uns gefesselt geknebelt hat ihm
hat mir immer die pistole an die schläfe
gehalten und habe geschrien nein und ich
bekam angst
bei diesem projekt geht es darum den
opfern eine stimme zu geben
in der restaurativen justiz sollen
wunden heilen können
ich sage oft mit namen und vornamen
benennen was ich getan habe nicht
einfach sein den heißen brei herum
sprechen
die kriminologin claudia christen
arbeitete fünf jahre lang in
chilenischen gefängnissen mit opfern und
tätern zusammen sie möchte dass die
restaurative justiert teil des schweizer
strafvollzuges wird es geht im zentrum
so fertig vormontiert und natürlich
konfrontation von das ist jene taten
dieser stelle und
bedürfnissen entspricht und die empathie
momentan wird höchste unfallquote nach
st
das opfer im mittelpunkt der strafjustiz
ein ganz neuer ansatz für die schweiz
[Musik]
wir sind wieder zurück da im train ist
robert ist kriminologe cloud einrichten
wo sie in detroit vorgesehen und
direktor von kolberg und rudolf schwarz
oder schwarz gemacht dass neulich
durchzubringen von täter und opfer
konnte und wer steht eigentlich biopsie
der neunziger jahre vom letzten
jahrhunderten nach das als modellversuch
durchgeführt mit bezug von dolberg -
quartett und einfache nutzer fest es ist
personalintensiv und nicht übertragbar
auf eine große europa fare
straftaten also eigentlich nicht wird
masse das ist das phänomen im
justizvollzug
also müssen angeben oder tiefer steht
sich auch nicht für das ist jetzt auch
als mittel und vor allem ganz wichtig
ist das image träger ist für babysitter
ist ganz wichtig
sondern das
opfer und tat als ganz wichtiges
und nachhaltiges natürlich gefährliche
außenseiter sind natürlich die daten
dialekt die software und daten zusammen
und dann gibt es natürlich die
gruppennamen herstelle die dialoge
gruppen und fan ig und obwohl sein
anderes übrig aber nicht didaktisch
windigsten und das ist natürlich weniger
intensiv und das wo insgesamt drei
monaten ausmachen sind derartige aber
obwohl sich der grund dass man das
überhaupt möchten oft heiße wahnsinnig
geflogen wenn es um mich natürlich nach
fertigstellung zahlt man die sache die
auch heutige ich nicht wusste was ist
jetzt wirklich genau passiert und wie
ist das zu halten so wie es genau dort
aber schon vorstellbar sagt
schwester gegenüber oder so
werden sich die eu setze
darum aber nicht
aber dir war das wünsche und sagen dass
sie die möglichkeit
ein tieferes bild
also
interessant
machen
seit
2001 muss wer der straftaten das heißt
mit den gefangenen
business umfeld sind persönliche
situation minute
delikt als vortat verhallt da nach dort
verhalten mit dem auto native handlicher
parat haben die gleiche situation hier
ja und wie würden sie jetzt ist ausgangs
vor beantwortet er immer da aber
vorgezeichnet völlig falsch ab so die
mehrheit
verhindern ist die war damit im traum
setzte die wehr hat die usk hof die
weite reise nach bali werde aber hat er
neben der linken seite ein jv 6 prozent
danke vielmals
rudolf schwarz danke viermal claudia
richten und auch deine begegnete er sein
ich bin sehr gespannt wie das jetzt
freut wirkt hat findet ihr könnt mit
peter filz wildung oder sind drehen oder
meine ich dass es überhaupt bringt zum
genie später zum sie in irgendeiner art
und wie ist verbessere ich schreibe
immer einig die
kommentarspalte wenn ihr vor geheimsten
unbedingt auch da ohne linie und wenn
ihr die ganze vielen dank sehen wo man
jetzt nur ausschnitte daraus zu eigens
die findet ihr alle da doch youtube